à la Une de La Voix du Nord et toujours
sur le thème de la sécurité des lycées
ont reçu des menaces d'attentat à
Roubaix Tourcoing et Wattrelos sur
l'espace numérique de travail des
parents et enseignants ont reçu des
menaces en rapport à l'interdiction de
la Baya à l'école le lycée Colbert de
Tourcoing a été fermé les autres sont
étroitement surveillés et ratissés par
des équipes de démineurs accompagnés de
chiens certains parents ne veulent plus
envoyer leurs enfants dans les lycées
concernés un petit mot marqué de Brest
c'est votre territoire
notamment sur le territoire de Roubaix
Tourcoing que connaît bien Gérald
Darmanin nous avons des mouvements
salafistes qui existent et nous avons
évidemment un combat qui est contre
cette affirmation de la laïcité dans nos
établissements moi je reste partisan du
port de l'uniforme dans les
établissements qui me semblent la
meilleure réponse pour garantir la
laïcité tout en garantissant la liberté
de religion
[Musique]